[Musique]
dans le cadre d'un appel à projets du
département pour les résidences
artistiques 2020-2021 patrimoine et
création
la bibliothèque départementale de la
réunion a établi un partenariat culturel
avec le rsma régiment du service
militaire adapté
un projet qui rassemble écriture
collecte de récits de vie création d'un
livret exposition mais avec des des
jeunes qu'on accompagne de manière vague
à proximité avec un programme artistique
qui est quand même assez intéressant
département à la mise en place et qui
permet ce dialogue finale entre des
créateurs des professionnels et j'en
veux dire des citoyens qu'ils soient en
insertion ou non d'ailleurs mais pour le
coup là ce sont des jeunes en insertion
c'est aussi une mission du département
d' accompagner l'insertion des jeunes
réunionnais dont essayer de programmer
vraiment plusieurs séances distinctes
une découverte de l'atelier de reliure
une découverte d'ouvragé pression
découverte du magasin est forcément des
couvertures de l'édifice et ça ça leur
permet de rentrer aussi dans l'histoire
de l'éducation finalement et cultura
c'est le but de la démarche depuis le 15
décembre 2020 stéphanie lebon a axé sa
résidence d'artistes autour de deux
temps un temps de recherche à la bdr de
saint-denis suivi de très séances
d'atelier ou rsm à de saint pierre avec
les jeunes du rsa on a mis en place des
ateliers d'écriture avec les supports
matériels de la bibliothèque et avec ses
ateliers d'écriture on a pu mettre en
place dès qu'on a pu écrire des textes
et faire des oeuvres plastiques qui met
en scène ses textes et ses oeuvres et
ses textes ont mis en forme dans un
livre et une exposition qui sera le qui
seront le projet de fin de résidence
pour moi je trouve que c'est bien parce
que déjà sa meilleure valeur les jeunes
du rsma ça montre qu' on n'est pas que
des gens têtus qui n'ont pas envie de
travailler au contraire il ya des gens
qui ont envie de réussir qui a envie
d'aller de l'avant
et moi je trouve que c'est une bonne
chose qui nous ont mis ce projet parce
que ça met un plan on va aller à leurrer
ces marais les jeunes aussi la
publication d'un ouvrage devrait avoir
lieu d'ici la fin de l'année
quant à l'exposition des travaux elle
est prévue pour début juillet
[Musique]